Brothers and sisters, respected guests,
thank you for joining us
on another edition to our series
on the book Zad al-Ma'ad
authored by the great and esteemed late
scholar of Islam, Shams al-Din
Up till now, we have discussed
how the Prophet Sallallahu alayhi wa
sallam would usually
stand for prayer, what he would say
at the beginning
of
his prayer.
We discussed the pause that would take
place.
We discussed that Ibn al-Qayyim
in summary
has essentially told us that the Prophet
Sallallahu alayhi wa sallam, when he
wished to pray,
he would stand for salah,
raise his hands
to his ears or to his shoulders,
this way and that,
and he would face his hands towards the
qibla,
[Arabic recitation]
And this would initiate his prayer.
Ibn al-Qayyim
tells us
that the Prophet Sallallahu alaihi
wasallam would never verbalize
his intentions for prayer.
That he Sallallahu alaihi wasallam
would never
put into words, I intend to pray such
and such, and we discussed that in
depth.
We also discussed that
the way a person should stand for prayer
as the scholars of Islam mention, and
this is a general rule we're going to
give now.
And that is that the scholars of Islam
agree
that one of the conditions of prayer
is that an individual face towards the
qibla. And this is what we want to
discuss here for a few minutes.
What do we mean by face towards the
qibla? Well, let's take the verse from
the Quran first. This is an issue that I
hope everybody will pay very close
attention to.
It's actually not very difficult to
understand, but it is an issue that has
a few details, and many people are mis-
construed about this issue of
facing the qibla.
When a person stands for prayer, he can
only face one direction.
One direction at a time.
And at the beginning of Islam, the
prophet Sallallahu alaihi wasallam would
face in his prayer towards
Baytul Maqdis, towards al-Masjid
al-Aqsa in Palestine.
And
he Sallallahu alaihi wasallam did this
because this is what he was commanded at
the beginning.
He was always commanded to pray towards
al-Masjid al-Aqsa.
This is the direction that
the Jews prayed towards.
This is the direction that the
Christians prayed towards.
Now, Sheikh ul Islam ibn Taymiyyah
rahimahullah tells us that
this was never
the actual qibla
of
the prophets and messengers.
He mentions rahimahullah
that the direction of salah
for every single prophet and messenger
was always towards al-Kaaba al-Bayt
al-Haram.
It towards Mecca.
All of them. From Adam alayhis salaam in
one opinion all the way to Muhammad
sallallahu alayhi wa sallam their
direction of prayer was always towards
al-Bayt al-Haram.
He mentions that
in the time between
Isa alayhis salaam and Muhammad
sallallahu alayhi wa sallam there was
about a 500-year gap.
This is known as al-Fatra.
Fatra fur-rusul. There was a about a
500-year gap
between Isa bin Maryam and the Prophet
[Arabic recitation]
During those years
the direction of prayer was actually
changed
amongst the people of the book.
And they started to face towards Bayt
al-Maqdis.
And one of the reasons
is that
Isa ibn Maryam alayhis salaam was born
in those areas.
And Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala tells us
in Surat Maryam
that
Maryam alayhas salaam
that she had taken a place
of solace and a place of seclusion for
herself,
Makan ash-Sharqiyyah,
in an eastern part, away from everyone.
[Arabic recitation]
where the innovation of praying towards
al-Bayt al-Maqdis came from amongst ahl
al-kitab."
And he mentions this verse, which is in
Surat Maryam.
And so the point here is that the
direction of prayer always for all of
the prophets and messengers was towards
Mecca.
It was an innovation that was introduced
by some of the followers of the prophets
in the time between
Musa, Isa, and Muhammad sallallahu
alayhi wasallam, in which they started
to face towards
Bayt al-Maqdis.
The Prophet sallallahu alayhi wasallam,
when he was commanded to pray,
at first and in Mecca, he was commanded
to pray towards Bayt al-Maqdis.
Why? Because this is the direction
that the people of the book were praying
at that time.
And a test for the people was being
formulated.
And so the Prophet Muhammad sallallahu
alayhi wasallam, being in Mecca,
what he would do
is he would face the Kaaba
and place the Kaaba
between himself and Bayt al-Maqdis.
So when he's standing for prayer, he's
actually facing towards the Kaaba and
Bayt al-Maqdis.
Right? So he's facing both.
Now when he
migrated, alayhis salatu wassalam, from
Mecca to Medina and the reason he did
this is because he knew salallahu alayhi
wasallam
that the original direction of prayer
for all of the prophets and messengers
was the Kaaba.
However, because due to a wisdom that
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
was implementing,
he at first was commanded to face
towards al-Bayt al-Maqdis.
And so, the Prophet salallahu alayhi
wasallam, you could say two birds with
one stone. He would stand with the Kaaba
between himself and Bayt al-Maqdis. He
would make his prayers and he would be
facing both at the same time.
Well, when he migrated from Mecca to
Medina, now we can no longer do that.
A person is either facing towards the
Kaaba,
hence facing away from Bayt al-Maqdis,
or a person is facing towards Bayt
al-Maqdis and hence facing away from the
Kaaba.
When the Prophet salallahu alayhi
wasallam arrived in Medina,
he was disturbed by this.
Because he wanted to pray towards the
direction of prayer that his brothers
from amongst the prophets and messengers
always prayed to.
And so,
the Prophet salallahu alayhi wasallam
would ask often
that Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala direct
him back to
the Kaaba, al-Bayt al-Haram, towards
Mecca to make salah.
And
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala finally
answered his request
in Surat al-Baqarah. He says subhanahu
[Arabic recitation]
fis sama'
falana walihanna ka'ba latin tar da'a
fawalli wajhaka shatral
And so, without too much detail,
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala mentions in so
many words,
"We see that your face looking up to the
heavens, awaiting when you will be given
permission to direct your prayer back to
the direction of al-Masjid al-Haram.
And we will now answer that request of
yours." Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says,
and he says, and this is the point here,
"Direct your faces in prayer towards the
center of al-Masjid al-Haram."
He says this to the Prophet sallallahu
alayhi wasallam, he says this to the
followers of the Prophet Muhammad
sallallahu alayhi wasallam. At that
point, prayer was then shifted from the
direction of Bayt al-Maqdis to the
direction of Mecca. Now,
what is it meant when Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala says, "Fawalli wajhaka shatr
al-Masjid al-Haram"?
Direct, because the word shatr in the
Arabic language literally means the
center
or the middle or the half,
right?
So, Allah says, "Direct yourself towards
the center of al-Masjid al-Haram, which
is the Kaaba."
And so, the scholars of Islam differ on
what is meant by this.
The majority of the scholars of fiqh say
that what is meant by "Direct yourself
towards the center," meaning the dead
center of the Kaaba,
is that if you see if it is in
it's in sight,
then you must direct your prayer
towards the Kaaba directly.
However, if the Kaaba is out of sight,
you're in some other land, you cannot
see it,
what is meant by shatr, and this is the
opinion of Ali ibn Abi Talib
Amir al-Mu'minin,
shatr al-Masjid al-Haram, meaning
nahwahu,
meaning towards its general direction.
What does that mean? Well, the scholars
of fiqh tell us it's roughly 45°.
Right?
So, what is meant by direct yourself
towards al-Masjid al-Haram, meaning in
its general direction.
The Prophet
said,
Ma bayna al-mashriqi wal-maghrib
qibla.
He said, "Between the
he says,
"Between the east and the
Ma bayna al-mashriqi wal-maghrib qibla.
Between the east and the west, there is
the direction of prayer, meaning
generally."
And so, a person doesn't have to have a
laser compass
to direct him exactly, precisely towards
the center of the qibla, of the Kaaba.
This is the opinion of
that it has to be as precise as
possible.
However,
when we look back to the mosques that
were around in the time of the Prophet
and I could say
the majority of the mosques on earth
that were built prior to about 100 years
ago
are all slightly off of the exact
direction of the qibla.
And that is fine. There is nothing wrong
with that in the correct opinion of the
scholars of Islam
because what is intended is the general
direction of the Qibla.
That if a person prays towards the
Qibla, as long as his shoulder
this is 45°. Is not facing towards the
Qibla. In other words, you are
completely facing away from it.
Then the prayer is correct. And we have
this problem all through.
I know this is a little bit off of the
subject, but it all falls into the
generality of our review here.
That
people will come and
bring you these spreadsheets and
coordinates
almost as if you need a
a
a military expert on ballistics, right?
And missile dynamics on how to direct
your prayer to the center of the Kaaba.
This is not necessary.
And some people will come and insist
that everybody in the entire masjid
their prayer is invalid. They're
slightly off. They're 5° or 10° off of
the exact direction of the Kaaba.
None of this is necessary
because the majority of the scholars of
Islam mention that what is intended is
the general direction of the Kaaba.
If this were the case, and the Kaaba is
finite in its in its width.
If a person had to pray
directly towards the Kaaba, no matter
where he was in the earth that means
that our rows in prayer could not be any
wider than the Kaaba. Because eventually
our row in prayer is going to be going
beside the Kaaba.
And none of the scholars of Islam have
ever said this.
So, when Allah says that we are to
direct ourselves towards the Qibla,
meaning we face the the Kaaba.
And based on this verse in the Quran,
the Prophet Sallallahu alaihi wasallam
would face every part of his body
towards the Qibla.
So, he would stand with his chest
His feet would not be standing out nor
in. His feet would be standing His toes
would be straight.
Shoulder width pointing directly towards
the Qibla, directly ahead. When he would
raise his hands, his hands would be
directly ahead.
Right?
Some scholars mention even the face
should be directly ahead.
Some even mention even the eyes should
be directly ahead.
Because this is what is meant by face
the Qibla, meaning every part of your
body possible to face towards the Qibla.
And so, the Prophet Sallallahu alaihi
wasallam, when he would make ruku, when
he would make sujud, when he would put
his hands on the ground to make sujud,
again, his hands would be shoulder width
apart and the fingers would be facing
towards the Qibla.
This all falls into the generality of
facing towards the Kaaba.
And so, when Ibn al-Qayyim Rahimahullah
tells us that the Prophet Sallallahu
alaihi wasallam, when he would raise his
hands,
he would raise them palms out facing
towards the Qibla, this is where this
comes from. And this is correct.
And so,
Ibn al-Qayyim then went on to to discuss
some of the
ad'iyat al-istiftah, which are the du'as
that are made at the beginning of the
prayer before Surat al-Fatiha. We
discussed the two brief pauses in the
Imam's recitation.
We as well discussed the way that the
Prophet Sallallahu Alaihi Wasallam would
generally recite the Quran one verse at
a time, elongating its final vowels.
As well, the Prophet Sallallahu Alaihi
Wasallam and his companions would all
say "Amen" together unanimously.
Now, Ibnul Qayyim Rahimahullah is going
to detail to us the verses that the
Prophet Sallallahu Alaihi Wasallam would
recite usually, customarily,
either by name or approximate length,
what he would recite in the various
in the various prayers. What he would
recite in Fajr, Dhuhr, Asr, Maghrib,
Isha, right? And how long each of these
prayers was, and how long the recitation
would be in each. Now,
you need to prepare yourself to be very
shocked because much of what the Muslims
do today, much of what we are forced to
do now as Imams in recitation and in
salah is
not very close to this. And the reason
for that is people are in too much of a
rush.
People
do not often have the patience to listen
to the Quran this much. And that's
unfortunate, right?
However,
it doesn't mean that
it doesn't mean that the prayer is
somehow deficient. No, the command of
Allah Subhana Wa Ta'ala in the Quran is
Faqra'u ma tayassara minhu. Recite as
much as is easy for you to recite in
prayer.
And the Prophet Sallallahu Alaihi
Wasallam said to
one of his companions that he had
assigned the Imam of the Masjid of his
village,
he said,
He says, "And make your recitation and
the length of your prayer,
make it according to the weakest amongst
the patrons that that the congregants
that pray behind you."
Meaning if
the weakest person, the person who is
sick or ill or unable to stand or old or
whatever it is,
is only able to stand for 5 minutes and
the rest, everybody else is able to
stand for
20, then we will go with five in
order to make things easy for everyone.
In the prayer of at night time, pray as
long as you like.
But after you if you are leading others
in prayer, this is something that is
very important to take into account.
Prayer is not meant
to be an exercise of how much pain you
can tolerate,
standing on your feet and so forth.
It is not meant to frustrate. It is
meant to
alleviate and maintain a connection and
a reminder for the people that pray
throughout their day.
However, we will mention
how the Prophet Sallallahu Alaihi
Wasallam would lead salah
and as a resident and as a traveler, and
there are many differences and we will
actually see how different
the length of our prayer and the
quality of our prayer has changed,
unfortunately.
That if the Prophet Sallallahu Alaihi
Wasallam in an audible prayer Fajr,
Maghrib, Isha, Salat al-Jumu', Salat
al-Eid, the Eid prayer, or Salat
al-Kusuf wal-Khusuf for lunar and solar
eclipses
the prophet or al-Istisqa كذلك is an
audible prayer. The prophet
upon concluding Surat al-Fatiha would
start to recite any other part of the
Quran after.
He says, "Occasionally, the prophet
would make his prayer exceptionally long
and lengthy."
Meaning in leading the companions in
prayer in these five obligatory prayers.
And sometimes he would make his prayer
in leading his companions exceptionally
brief
due to some circumstances such as
travel or other than that. Maybe war,
travel, battle, sickness, fear, whatever
it is, the prophet
may shorten his prayer to accommodate
for those
set of particular circumstances. Ibn
al-Qayyim then gives us the norm,
however. He says the norm
Most
of the time his prayer would be medium
length, neither long nor short.
Right? So, the norm is a a well-balanced
medium length
that is neither long nor short, and the
exception would be lengthiness and
shortness. Now, what is meant by that?
And the prophet Sallallahu alaihi
wasallam
in salat al-fajr
would usually read in the two raka'
dispersed between the two raka'
between 60 and 100 verses.
Now, what what kind of verses? We're not
talking about Surat al-Ma'idah verses.
We're not talking about Surat al-Rahman
verses.
Right? Neither extremely long nor
extremely short. We're speaking about
medium length verses. Right?
Salat al-fajr would be about 60 to 100
verses.
Which is very different than what we
recite today. Most of the time in our
prayer
in about 10 minutes for salat al-fajr
we will usually hear no more than about
15 to 20 verses.
He says, "Wa sallaha bi Surat Qaf."
[Arabic recitation]
He had also recited Surat al- salat
al-fajr
in
by reciting Surat Qaf, which is about
two and a half pages.
"Wa sallaha bi Surat al-Rum." And he's
also
recited in
salat al-fajr Surat al-Rum. Surat
al-Rum is from al-mi'in, which are
roughly 100 verses each.
And Surat al-Rum is about
seven or eight pages in the pages of the
popular mushaf today.
Also, the prophet Sallallahu alaihi
wasallam was narrated in fajr to have
prayed led his companions in fajr
reciting Idha shams kuwwirat, which is
about a page long.
He as well
recited
in salat al-fajr in both rak'
idha zulzilatil ardu zilzalaha, which is
about a third of a page. It's a very
short chapter, which most of us are
familiar with. And it was narrated that
he recited in both rak', the first and
second of fajr, idha zulzilatil ardu
zilzalaha.
So, he was and this was
in
travel. He was traveling.
And so, he recited surat az-zalzalah in
the first and second
rak' of the prayer.
The companion who narrates this,
he says
fala adri
ata'ammada dhalika am nasi.
The companion who narrates this, he says
the Prophet Sallallahu alayhi wasallam
recited in the first rak' and the
second rak'
idha zulzilatil ardu zilzalaha. So, he
recited surat al-fatiha az-zalzalah
second rak', surat al-fatiha and
az-zalzalah. And the companion said,
"I'm not sure if he did that on purpose
or if he
merely had forgotten."
And that's something that can happen
with the Prophet Sallallahu alayhi
wasallam. Either way,
it shows us that if a person repeats the
same verses
in
the first rak' and the second, that
this is fine. This is all into the
generality of recite anything that is
easy for you of the Quran.
But
a strong opinion is that this was out of
forgetfulness, meaning he didn't mean
particularly to do this on purpose that
people after him would continue to
recite occasionally in salat al-fajr
az-zalzalah
in both rak'. How do we know this?
Because he never repeated it. It only
happened once.
And we see that his companions,
radiyallahu anhu, Abu Bakr, and Umar,
and Uthman, and Ali were not narrated to
have done this either in leading prayer.
So, many scholars mentioned that this
was out of forgetfulness. And that has
that has nothing
to do with his prophethood, sallallahu
alayhi wasallam. Meaning, he is a human
being. He may forget things, right? Just
we humans forget. However,
it does not mean that he would be
made to forget something that is crucial
to his prophethood, right? for
example, forgetting some
principles of Islam or something like
this. This is a different issue. And
this
is an issue of belief and creed,
which is found elsewhere in other types
of classes.
Ibn al-Qayyim, rahimahullah, he
continues.
He says, wa sallaha bil mu'awwidhatayn,
[Arabic recitation]
And it's mentioned, it's narrated that
the Prophet, sallallahu alayhi wasallam,
also led Salat-ul-Fajr
reciting the last two chapters of the
Quran, surah al-Falaq, surah an-Nas. Qul
a'udhu birabbil falaq, qul a'udhu
birabbin nas in the second rak'.
The first in the first rak'. And he
was in travel during this time. So,
we see that Ibn al-Qayyim, rahimahullah,
he begins, and this is why this book is
so important. He starts with giving us a
general principle.
Meaning, if we look at all the body of
information
that we have about the traditions and
the ways of the Prophet Muhammad,
sallallahu alayhi wasallam, his
statements, his actions, his
legislation. If we look at all that, we
start to see patterns. The only way you
can see that pattern
is you have to be very, very high on the
ladder of knowledge. Only the major
scholars can pick up on patterns like
that because the body of information is
just so
vast. Ibn al-Qayyim happens to be one of
those scholars
who can tell us of these patterns.
So, he gives us the pattern, he gives us
the general principle, and then he
mentions the narrations for us. And this
is why this book is so crucial.
He says, "Wa sallaha
meaning Surat al-Fajr
fastaftaha
Surat al-Mu'minun
[Arabic recitation]
fi al-rak' al-ula
akhadhathu
sa'lah faraka'a."
He says,
"And also, it was narrated that the
Prophet Sallallahu alayhi wasallam began
in Salat al-Fajr
to
in the first rak' to recite Surat
al-Mu'minun.
And he reached roughly
the halfway point or maybe let's say
a little over a third of the chapter
where he reached the story of Musa and
[Arabic recitation]
which is towards the middle, but it's
actually part of the first half.
This is in the first rak', and then he
began to cough.
Whatever, he started to cough, whether
he was ill that day or
you know,
something in swallowing or breathing,
whatever, he started to cough Sallallahu
alayhi wasallam, and this coughing
persisted, and so he chose to make
ruku', which tells us something. And
that is that if the Imam
is presented with some kind of unique
problem
in his prayer,
such as
some people have allergies, and I'm sure
you've seen this, once they start
sneezing, they can't stop. They just
sneeze and sneeze and sneeze and sneeze
20 times, 30 times, right?
If this happens to an Imam
while he's leading prayer,
nobody is going to benefit the Imam or
the people praying behind him to listen
to him sneeze all day or all night in
the prayer.
If the sneezing will not stop,
and it will be a disturbance,
then he needs to leave the prayer and
have somebody else from behind him
lead in his place, and he can excuse
himself, right? And this goes for
anybody who is praying as well in
Jama'.
I mean, I've prayed in salah
where somebody starts to sneeze. Of
course, this is before Corona day. If it
happened during Corona day, you know,
Allah help him, whoever this is that
sneezes. But before this,
a person would start to sneeze because
of some dust or something on the carpet
or chemicals or whatever, whatever it
is. Some people have very very sensitive
sinuses,
and sit there and sneeze
literally for 10 minutes straight
in the prayer. Not any one of us is
enjoying our prayer. He's definitely not
praying,
right? The Imam, we can't hear the
recitation, and we'll just continue to
sneeze and sneeze and sneeze.
This is inappropriate.
If a person starts salah, they shouldn't
just stop for no reason. But if they
have an excuse to stop, sometimes they
must stop. If a person breaks his wudu,
if there's a fire, if there's an
emergency,
right? A person doesn't just continue to
pray.
Prayer is not supposed to be something
that, you know, once you're locked into
it, you can't stop. There are instances
where a person can stop and there are
instance when instances when a person
must stop.
If a person is coughing or if a person
is sneezing, the Imam, and it's, you
know, three, four times, something where
he needs to catch his breath, let's say.
Or let's say the Imam is reciting a part
of the Quran
and he misrecites some part and he gets
confused because of his, you know,
memorization. It happens to every single
person, right?
No matter how
perfectly you memorize the Quran, you
must keep in mind that this is the words
of Allah, the sublime, the divine. You
will never
conquer the Quran. It will never happen,
right?
No matter who you are,
you will
misremember,
misspeak, misrecite some part of the
Quran because the book of Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala is the ultimate
in
will will always win. You will never
conquer it in that sense.
Even the companions, even the Prophet
Muhammad sallallahu alaihi wasallam, in
very rare instances, was narrated to
have missed a verse
in his recitation, right?
And the companions radiyallahu anhu
would remind him of it.
this is a momentary thing. This
doesn't mean that the Quran has somehow
become corrupted. It means that we are
all human beings and this is the divine
words of rabbil alameen, which we will
never conquer, right?
And so,
if the Imam catches on a verse and can't
figure it out,
he doesn't need to sit there and have a
shouting match with him and the people
behind him,
right?
It's fine for him to collect his
thoughts, make ruku.
Just as the Prophet Sallallahu Alaihi
Wasallam here
started to cough, he made a little core,
right? To catch his breath, to
regain his composure.
And this happens.
Unfortunately, we have
strayed
from many of our
much of our proper understanding of the
Quran and Sunnah.
I'm going to give you an example.
The Sunnah,
the way
that a person must correct the Imam.
This is called al-fath alal Imam. It's a
huge problem,
right?
So, the Imam is praying, he's leading
salah.
People are behind him who happen to have
memorized the same verses that this Imam
has memorized.
If the Imam makes a mistake in his
recitation,
there is an etiquette and a way that he
is corrected, if at all even. There are
instances where he should just be left
and not even corrected,
because it will cause more problems than
it will solve,
right? And this is an issue of masalih
and mafasid. Because the Quran is
it is established, it's not going to
change.
Because an Imam misremembered and
misrecited doesn't mean that the Quran
has become corrupted, right? It just
means that he had misremembered. This is
one person of millions and millions and
centuries of centuries of preservation
of the Quran.
And so for me to insist that the Imam
must correct himself in the middle of
his recitation in salah, this actually
may cause anxiety, it may cause discord,
and the Quran was never meant to cause
those things.
And so,
we flip things, right? Because we have
become so detached from the tradition of
our prophet Sallallahu alaihi wasallam.
So for example,
the sunnah
is if the Imam makes a mistake in the
prayer,
meaning
he stands up for an additional
additional rak' that he's not to stand
for, or he misses a rak'.
Instead of praying four for salat
al-isha, he forgets and sits down on the
third to make tashahhud, and he thinks
it's the fourth.
The sunnah is that every single person
in the masjid who notices that mistake,
if they are male to say subhanallah, and
if they are female to to clap their
hands.
Right? Cuz the men and women
usually
it's now we've become very comfortable
and have big big masajid, and the women
have their own section, but usually we
would all be in one masjid. The women
would
line up for prayer behind the men, and
the women would not shout, they would be
in the back, they would clap their
hands, and the men would say subhanallah
to remind the Imam, to alert him that a
mistake has been made.
However, the sunnah,
the etiquettes of prayer
is that the person who prays directly
behind the Imam
that this be a person who is most well
recited
and most knowledgeable of the Quran
after the Imam.
Right?
Why? Because when the Imam makes a
mistake in his recitation
and articulates in his demeanor
that he needs somebody to
help him to get on course with that
mistake in his recitation.
Then the Sunnah is only one person who
is directly behind the Imam closest to
him correct him.
Right?
I've I've prayed where people
the Imam is praying in a completely
other building.
And he makes a mistake and the people in
the other building start to scream out
the correction of the verse.
And unfortunately, this is very very
unfortunate. Why?
Well, there's a number of reasons, but
one of the main reasons is this is my
time to show that I know. And this is
very very dangerous.
The scholars of Islam teach us that hub
al-zuhur
yaqsim al-zuhur.
Desiring to be noticed
and be
you know, on a pedestal in front of
people will actually lead to a person's
destruction, their moral compass.
The point is is that if the Imam makes a
mistake, usually
in his recitation, you'll have no fewer
than 10 people shouting at him from all
directions. And sometimes shouting
completely different verses. They don't
even know what what surah he's reciting.
He's in one valley and they're a
completely other one.
Shouting conflicting verses at the Imam.
He has no idea who is saying what.
This is not helpful to anybody at all.
Yet, we still we see as well that if the
Imam makes a mistake in something that
everybody should have noticed, such as
he stands up for a fifth rak' in Isha
or he sits at a third rak' in Isha.
Maybe one person will say subhanallah
ala istihya.
And this is exactly the opposite of how
it should be.
This is the reason why the prophet
salallahu alaihi wasallam said
that those who are most mature and most
knowledgeable amongst you are the ones
who should pray directly behind me. Why?
The scholars of Islam mention that one
of the reasons is that those who are of
most understanding and those who are of
most memorization of the Quran, they are
the ones who should pray directly behind
the Imam for a number of reasons. Number
one, perhaps
the Imam will need somebody to correct
him
in his recitation and there is a very
there's a complete methodology to that,
which we will get into at another time
inshallah.
Or the Imam something may happen.
He may break his wudu. He may remember
that he doesn't have wudu.
Something may occur.
Maybe he has some kind of
pain or something happens where he needs
to excuse himself from the prayer, in
which case the person directly behind
him, the Imam should appoint that person
to step forward and complete the leading
of that prayer.
So, this is these are some of the
rulings with regards to
the salah and what the prophet sal
alaihi wasallam would recite and how he
would lead prayer. We will continue in
our next installment inshallah. thank
you for watching. subhanakallahumma
[Arabic recitation]
ajma'in walhamdulillah rabbil alamin.